hi welcome my name is Mark and you are
at the Intel gaming super demo and what
we're showcasing here is gaming on Intel
Architecture anytime anywhere so all the
devices that we have here from phones
all the way up to 4k gaming notebooks
you can take on the go with you we even
have a very small gaming desktop which
is able to run steam OS as a steam
machine but what we want to showcase for
you today here is 4k gaming it is Batman
Arkham origin and it is running on an
alienware 18 which is a very powerful
gaming notebook running a 4th gen intel
core i7 processor it's a quad core
processor it is also running dual 780m
graphics cards in sli and we're able to
get 4k resolution while playing the game
which we're going to show you in action
right here and it looks stunning so the
really cool thing about 4k gaming is we
are delivering technology today that's
future proofing your gaming experience
into the future so 4k monitors and TVs
are coming down in price dramatically
and you can definitely you know talk to
all the great TV and monitor vendors but
4k gaming is possible today so
everything we're showing today including
this alienware 18 is off the shelf we
purchased this from Dell and we also
purchased this panasonic 65-inch 4k TV
which is running 4k at 60 Hertz right
from Panasonic as well so all this is
available today if you are looking to
get the utmost out of your gaming
experience all right up until recently
in order to get 4k gaming you would have
to have a very very powerful desktop
with thousands of dollars worth of
discrete graphics cards in there and
we're able to show that today on an
alienware 18 notebook and what we're
showcasing here again it's all about
gaming anytime anywhere and something
that was very large and not so much
portable is now able to be transported
anywhere with you so that your game goes
with you wherever you are whenever you
are and again thank you so much for
coming by the intel booth checking out
her gaming super demo and we would
showing you 4k gaming arc Arkham origins
on the alienware 18